you ever hear any anything back from
Konya yeah we'll talk about that off
there go yeah not not bad nah yeah you
just hit me I think it's better for that
guy to not do podcast just make great
music this is why I don't think you're
on this why I don't think it's gonna
work for you you're not gonna let him
rant like Trump does and get away with
all that stuff it's not what you do what
truck listen I'm saying you never saw
that video of him out making his own
like book and vocabulary and Trump like
that'd be cool dude okay you're on my
side right I'm a Kanye friend I'm
a-tellin fear I am - yeah it's amazing
I think she's incredibly eccentric and I
think if you're gonna be credibly
eccentric the way he is you're gonna
have a lot of nutty thoughts and ideas
and he also has some mental health
issues like legitimate that he's
discussed yet that are public yeah and
that that I think in some ways may
contribute to his art because he's off
medication he was on medication for a
while and the way he talked about it he
was saying that it was stifling him it
was [ __ ] him up telling him yeah I
was dulling his ability to create how
could it not it's a fine it's a fine
line though right because what made him
amazing what made him amazing is this
wild mind that he asked but this wild
mind is not it's not based on like
mathematical truth and logic and reason
it's based on this ability to just go
with the flow and think what you think
and be confident your decisions and just
be and this be in touch with your
emotions and your feelings and I mean
he's a [ __ ] incredibly prolific
artist to leave that guy alone and I
think that Kim Kardashian situation is
perfect because she loves him they have
a family together I bet she kind of
keeps him grounded her and her family
obviously have an amazing business sense
so like they'll keep all the money tight
keep everybody together I mean she's got
[ __ ] more loot than God would you
ever have Kim Kardashian on your podcast
you know what I'd have her I don't ever
come on and talk about our decision to
help with prison reform because I think
that's really admirable there's a lot of
people that have made a lot of money and
they've gotten real famous and they
didn't do [ __ ] with it but what she's
done she's completely free yes she's
actually and she's actually pushed a
narrative that you can do something like
this and she's talked to Trump and she's
visited in the White House and she's got
I think something like 18 people freed
from prison that were wrongly
incarcerated pretty Christo respect to
her I don't know I don't know I ever
want to make a Kim Kardashian joke for
the rest of my life
plus I made a bunch of him lady but even
if I did even if your last special one
before the one before but even if that
was Bruce that's right but if I did I
mean I mean but I mean what she's done
is like she's decided to make a
difference she didn't have to me know
she had friends [ __ ] she could just buy
diamonds to get her toes done she
decided to make a difference you know so
I respect her 100% man there's a lot of
[ __ ] there's there's people that
learn and grow you know want to sell
people short and write people off and
cancel people because of this or that
and turn them into a noun yes who you
are changing